depuis quelques semaines une plateforme
écologique a été installée à côté de
cette péniche au port marly
ce système est basé sur la
phytoépuration il traite les eaux usées
de ce bateau qui sont déversées via des
tuyaux avec ce jardin flottant
en fait il ya une bascule d'une semaine
sur l'autre c'est à dire que pendant une
semaine le jardin est arrosé d'un côté
et pendant une autre semaine le jardin
est arrosé de l'autre côté à l'autre
averse la filtration à sable et au fond
c'est un système pyramidal au fond on a
en a une pompe qui varient arroser le
jardin et l'ensemble des deux jardins
d'ailleurs mais met doucement et
renvoyer une partie de ces eaux dans les
filtres uv une fois dans les filtres uv
l'eau est une nouvelle fois traité pour
être propre puis rejetés dans la seine
ce jardin d'assainissement peut être
utilisée par une famille de quatre à
cinq personnes
la vie les pilotes sur le projet il est
innovant l'enfance ou la phytoépuration
ça existe depuis très longtemps il est
innovant uniquement sur sur le fait
qu'ils soient sur une sur une barque et
qui soit
à couple c'est à dire pour traiter des
bateaux des bateaux logement à terme si
les tests sont concluants ce dispositif
pourrait être généralisé sur le secteur
il n'est pas encore commercialisé pour
l'instant mais le prix de cette
plateforme avoisine les 15000 euros